bonsoir et bienvenue dans soir 3 la vie
reprend sur la place djemaa el fna en
plein coeur de marrakech là où se
retrouvent côte à côte les marocains et
les près de 10 millions de touristes qui
transitent chaque année mais depuis
l'attentât d'hier le coeur n'y est plus
tout à fait le dernier bilan fait état
d'une quinzaine de morts et d'une
vingtaine de blessés on fera le point
tout à l'heure selon les derniers
éléments de l'enquète l'engin explosif
aurait été actionnée à distance pour le
gouvernement en tout cas la piste d'al
qaïda ne fait plus de doute
l'enquêté se poursuit donc aujourd'hui
les autorités ont d'ailleurs révélé
qu'un message vidéo d'al qaïda au
maghreb islamique postée sur internet il
ya trois jours
viser directement le maroc le point avec
nos envoyés spéciaux sur place
huguette et mark saville les fameuses
calèche sont de retour sur la place
djemaa el fna
comme si de rien n'était comme si
l'horrible verrue du café argana n'avait
été qu'un mauvais cauchemar
mais les choeurs sont lourds et par
moments la colère envers les auteurs de
l'attentât des bornes sur 100 des
terroristes impardonnables dans la vie
soit séjour à l'hôpital ibn e tefal où
la majorité des victimes sont soignées
la plupart sont ce soir hors de danger
seul l'un des huit français restent dans
un état critique
mais quelle que soit la gravité le
traumatisme est profond
ils montrent un étage pour profiter
prévu on s'installe et je savais pas par
monts et par ennui laissera minutes
après le musicien s'est ainsi laissé
exploser une grande flamme pour la faune
la fumée
les cris et après factiva nous chez des
patients qui ont pour la plupart des
lésions traumatiques au niveau des
membres inférieurs
soit tu sois type de dons plus tation
traumatique ou de fractures aux dents
qu'il ya des personnes qui ont été
amputés carrément y en a trois dans les
décombres du café les enquêteurs
marocains second départ des policiers
français de l'antiterrorisme met les
bouchées doubles pour ramasser les
indices et apporter ne serait ce qu un
début d'explication souffrances endurées
tutsi meurtri et le phénomène est rare
au maroc des femmes et des enfants se
sont rassemblés silencieusement
il y à quelques instants sur la place